تمام
ا مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم ا عام جديد
سعيد ان شاء الله يكون عليكم وعلى كل
حبايبكم وعلى كل الناس بقالنا كتير ما
اتقابلناش ولكن ده كان د واعي اولا ازمه
غزه بالاضافه طبعا الى ازمه انقطاع
الكهرباء في مصر ودي لا تخفى عليكم انا في
انتظار الاسئله
و ان شاء الله نجيب اكبر عدد منها خلال
الساعه المقبله هلا عبد الرحمن السويفي
انت صدقنا من زمان يا استاذ عبد الرحمن
اهلا وسهلا حسن الشمري وعليكم
السلام محمد العساف اسعد الله مساءك سيد
واسعد الله مساءك محمد اهلا بكم جميعا
ماجد كريستيانو
رونالدو ربنا يخليكم جميعا السؤال اول
سؤال جالي وعلييكم السلام ده قناه
الشرقيه بح لحظه عشان ما شاء الله الاسئله
بدات تتدفق مباشره اول سؤال اخونا محمد
بيتكلم عن ما هو مستقبل اسرائيل هذا هو
اول سؤال طبعا السؤال كبير جدا لا استطيع
ان انا از عندي اجابه قاطعه عليه ولكن
اسرائيل مستقبلها اسرائيل ماضيها كان مبني
على فكره استخدام
القوه مستقبلها بين اعتبارين الاعتبار
الاول او احتمالين ان هي تقبل بدوله
فلسطينيه حتى لو كانت دوله فلسطينيه دون
توقعات
الفلسطينيين وفي الحاله دي الاسرائيليين
بيعتقدوا ان ذلك سوف يكون تنازلا في
الحاله ديت يبقى ممكن تعيش مع جيرانها
دوله اسرائيليه ودوله فلسطينيه هذا الحل
لا يريده الاسرائيليون ابدا ولا دوله
فلسطينيه اصغر من ال 22% ولا اصغر من 20%
ولا منزوعه السلاح ولا غير منزوعه السلاح
الى اخره الحل الثاني ان تبقى دوله واحده
يعيش فيها الفلسطينيون واليهود من البحر
للنهر كلهم في دوله واحده تحت حكم الامر
الواقع وده يرفضه الاسرائيليون تماما ولكن
قد يضطر اليه
اضطرارا هذا هو واذا قبلت هي بح للدوله
الواحده هذا يعني انتهاء المشروع الصهيوني
باكمله
وتبخر المشروع الصهيوني والحلم اليهودي
ويبقى اليهود عايشين مع العرب وهم مدركين
لهذه الحقيقه ولذلك
يقاومون خلاف كده سوف يظل هناك صراعا الى
يوم القيامه
ا
فراس من لبنان تحيه طيبه ربنا يخليك هل
جبهه جنوب لبنان معه اسرائيل كما هي الان
لها تاثير قوي على اداء الجيش الاسرائيلي
في حربه على غزه ام هي مجرد ضغط على
المستوطنين والاقتصاد الاسرائيلي بشكل عام
لا طبعا بتمثل ضغط يعني انا عارف ان في
ناس يقول لك احنا كنا منتظرين اكثر من حزب
الله احنا اتكلمنا في القضيه دي قبل كده
وعلشان لا اعيد ما ذكرناه في حلقات كثيره
اكيد يعني اللي بيعملوا حزب الله بيمثل
تشتتا للجبهه الاسرائيليه اللي بيعمل حزب
الله مش قليل يعني هو ما هو في حاله
اشتباك ولكن اشتباك منخفض الكثافه مع
الاسرائيليين فهو بيجبر الاسرائيليين
اجبارا على انه يفرغ جزء من قواته في
الشمال وجزء من قدراته الاستخباراتيه والى
اخره يعني وتكلفه على الامريكان والحلفاء
اللي هم
موجودين املا او تحسبا لاي هجوم من حزب
الله فالاجابه نعم ضغطا وهذا الضغط زاد مع
هجمات الحوثيين اللي الحقت خسائر واضحه
بالاقتصاد الاسرائيلي ولكن الحقت ايضا
خسائر دول اخرى في ا في المنطقه
يعني السعوديه مصر غيرهم يعني وباليمن
نفسها
ا رايك ده عمر رايك في تصريحات مصطفى
الفقهي ما هي تصريحاته يا صديقي قول لي
وانا اقول لو كان لي رايي فيها يعني لان
الدكتور مصطفى الفقي كثير المقابلات وغزير
التصريحات فلا ادري ايها اي تصريحات تشور
اليها محمد قول دلوقتي حالا وانا لو اعرف
هقول لحضرتك محمد وسط حاله السعار الذي
تعيشه اسرائيل هل ستث هل ستؤثر الخسائر
البشريه والاقتصاديه وتجعلها تنهي الحرب
وما هو الثمن الذي سيعرض سيعاد هذا الكم
من الضحايا والدمار لو انت بتتكلم على
اسرائيل ما في شك انه الخسائر اللي بتتعرض
لها اسرائيل بتدفعها دفعا الى دراسه
سيناريو انهاء الحرب لو لاحظت حضرتك في
احنا النهارده في اليوم ال 82 في اليوم ال
82 يعني بعد 822 يوم من الحرب توقعات
اسرائيل هبطت تماما احنا كنا بنتكلم الاول
على تصريحات بتقول لن تنتهي هذه الحرب الا
بالقضاء على حماس تماما تماما ولما بيقول
حماس هو مش بيقول حماس وقصده حماس وكل
جماعات المقاومه لان هناك مجموعه فصائل
اخرى اهم اكبرها حماس لكن حماس ليست وحدها
هذا واحد اثنين كان نتنياهو بيقول لن
تنتهي هذه الحرب وتعود الاوضاع كما كانت
عليه ليس فقط في قطاع غزه ولكن في قطع غزه
وفي الضفه وقال في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
باكملها بعد 82 يوم احنا بنتكلم على
توقعات ثانيه خالص او على سقف منخفض جدا
بيتكلم على انه قد نقبل الخطه المصريه
والخطه المصريه دي بتقول ايه انه والله
ننهي العدائيات ويحصل تبادل للاسرى ثم
تاتي حكومه تكنوقراط وكلمه تكنوقراط
معناها انه يجي مثلا وزير ري مهندس ري
وزير ا الصحه يبقى طبيب مالوش علاقه
بالسياسيين ودول يحكموا قطاع غزه لما ادق
في الكلام هو التكنوقراط هيجوا منين
هيكونوا موظفين يحكموا الامور الفنيه لكن
تدره القوى الاساسيه على الارض اللي هي
حماس والجهاد وكل الفصائل الاخرى كما هو
الحال في لبنان واسرائيل بتقول طب ندرس
القصه اسرائيل بعد ما كانت بتتكلم عن
ضروره تدمير حماس دلوقتي بتقول والله ممكن
احنا نقبل بانه بعض قر حماس يغادروا
الساحه
وصيغه زي صيغه حكومه التكنوقراط التوقعات
هبطت
كثيرا انا بتجي لي رسائل انا اسف ان انا
اطلت في عشان الاخوه بمناسبه الرساله اللي
كانت بتجي لي وبتقول لي يعني انه انت
بتقول كلام يعني
فيه تمجيد للمقاومه وانه الكلام زي شبهوه
مره حد بتعبير قاسي قاللي زي احمد سعيد
احمد سعيد لم لا يعرفه كان اذاعيا مصريا
كان بارز جدا في ايام 67 وكان يتحدث عن
الانتصارات الكبيره التي حققها القوات
المصريه بينما كانت القوات المصريه طبعا
بتمنى باكبر هزيمه في تاريخ خها يعني
الحقيقه الكلام ده غير منصف مش ل يعني انا
مش مشكله اولا الدفاع عن المقاومه ده شرف
ل لكن الفكره مش في كده انا بتكلم ان انا
حقيقي لا انا يعني لو كان في خسائر في
المقاومه انا كنت قلت يعني لانه انا هخدع
الناس ليهه المساله على الارض اسرائيل حتى
هذا اليوم طبعا تمكنت من الحاق
خسائر كارثيه بال بالقطاع في البنيه
التحتيه وبالناس وهذه ماساه لكن هي على
المستوى العسكري وفي مواجهه للمقاومه
مسلسل من الازلال وليس لها وحدها ولكن
للولايات المتحده وذكركم مثلا ان وزير
خارجيه الولايات المتحده من حوالي شهر
مثلا كان بيقول على الهواء وعده مرات
واثقون ان قياده حماس استخباراتيا تحت
مستشفى الشفاء واثقون و ار سيرتن شور
ولذلك احنا ادينا ضوء اخضر القوات
الاسرائيليه ان تفعل ما تشاء في هذا
المستشفى حنا وصلوا الى مستشفى المشفى لم
يجدوا شيئا انتكاسه خساره فضيحه
استخباراتيه لاسرائيل وللولايات
المتحده ما المقترح الذي قدمته مصر لوقف
اطلاق النار يا عبد الرحمن تقريبا انا لسه
قايله حالا مصر بتقول اولا هي مصر اعلنته
بشكل غير رسمي يعني ما حصلش كده ان وزاره
الخارجيه او المخابرات المصريه اعلنت عليه
رسميا وقالت بعد شويه ان ده مقترح او
افكار لكن الخطه النهائيه حين تقبل
الاطراف لكن ما تسرب عن هذه الخطه بيقول
ببساطه انه يحصل وقف لاطلاق النار مبدئيا
لمده اسبوعين مرحله اولى يتم فيها تبادل
اسرى في تفاصيل كتيره بس مش مهمه يعني
نبدا بالعجز العجزه والاطفال من
الاسرائيليين ثم المجندات السته اللي
موجودين ثم الى اخره يعني يعني نبدا
بالمدنيين والعسكريين بغض النظر عن
التفاصيل اللي هي مش مفيده قوي في مقابل
طبعا اخراج السجناء الفلسطينيين من السجون
الاسرائيليه اين نبتدي نتكلم على اليوم
التالي او ما يسمونه بذا دي افتر يعني
ماذا بعد وقف اطلاق النار نبتدي نعمل
مفاوضات المفاوضات دي بتقول ايه انه
اسرائيل بتقول لا يمكن ان تبقى غزه كما
كانت قبل 7 اكتوبر وحماس والجهاد بيقول
لهم
يعني فلتذهبوا الى الجحيم مش هيحصل تغيير
فمصر بتقول طب انا عندي حل
نعمل بدل ما تحكم حماس لان ده صعب هيكون
وجه امر غير مقبول نعمل حكومه تقرو كرات
او حكومه فنيه يعني ناس ما ينمو لا الحماس
ولا الجهاد ولا ولكن دول ناس زي ما كنت
بقول ناس ياتوا من تخصصات مختلفه
ويحكموا احنا عندنا السوابق في كل دول
العالم في هذا من هذا النوع من الحكومه
ناس مش من احزاب ولا من قوه بس الكلام في
النهايه انه مستحيل هذه الحكومه
التكنوقراط واسرائيل تبقى فاهمه كده
مستحيل هم مالهمش قوه على الارض رئيس
الحكومه ده بيجي ليه قوه لازم يكون ليه
حزب على الارض ليه جماعه لكن هاجي انا من
الجامعه ولا هاجي انا من من شركه ولا من
بنك احكم طب طب مين يعني يعني ما هو
القوات الحسودي هتروح فين وقوات الجهاد
وقوات كل طوائف المقاومه هتروح فين دول
اللي هيكونوا هم القوى الحقيقيه فيبقى
التكنوقراط دول هيكونوا هم الواجهه وتكون
حماس والجهاد من خلفهم كما هو هو الحال في
لبنان على سبيل المثال حزب الله لا يشارك
في الحكم بصفته حزب الله ولكن من خلال
شخصيات مستقله محسوبه على حزب الله طب
واسرائيل تقبل بد ليه نوع من اي حجه
للخروج وانهاء المازق ليس اكثر يعني
ا سلام عليكم
ا استاذنا المحترم الله يحفظك يا ابو ادم
لو كتبتوا اساميكم بالعربي او يعني
الانجليزي زي ما كاتب كده ابو ادم هيكون
اسهل بدل الاسماء الحركيه عبد
العزيز عليكم السلام محمد مساء الخير ما
رؤيه ما رؤيه الحرب في غزه بعد شهر لا مش
بعد شهر انا قلت بعد 81 بالمناسبه كنت
مطلع النهارده حلقه مع صديقي الكتور احمد
فؤاد انور والله حلقه لطيفه وصغيره يعني
كنت النيه ان انا اطلعها النهارده وهي
متسجله يعني بس ام اظن بما ان احنا طلعنا
مباشره النهارده على الاكثر هتكون مذاعه
بتتكلم على مسار الحرب بخلال اول 81 يوم
انما انا في تقديري تقديري يعني انه
الطرفين مجهدين لكن اسرائيل عجزت في
المحصله النهائيه عن تحقيق اهدافها
الرئيسيه
والثانويه في هذه الحرب ده تاديري وقد
اكون مخطئ يعني ما قيمه العقوبات
الاوروبيه على افراد
حماس والله الاوروبيه تحديدا طب انا ممكن
عندي نقترح نقول العق الدوليه بقى لان
الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده ودول في
المنطقه طبعا بس طبعا بتبقى مؤثره ولكن
احنا قدامنا نماذج يعني حزب الله عليه
عقوبات من كل دول العالم وتاقلم وعاش مع
هذه العقوبات عندنا طالبان عليها عقوبات
من كل دول العالم وتاقلم وعاشت مع
العقوبات عندنا ايران عندنا فنزويلا
وطبعا عندنا روسيا مؤخرا يعني العقوبات
اللي هي الكاسحه دي اثبتت ان انها تجعل
الحياه صعبه لكنها تستفز عند الانسان او
عند الحكومات او عند الشعوب سبل التحدي
والتاقلم مع اوضاع صعبه فما تاثيرها انت
شوف انت اديلك مثال اوضح بعد حرب اسمها
ايه اسمها حارس الاسوار ولا مش عارف ايه
في مايو
2021 بعد هذه العمليه خرج الاسرائيليون
احنا عرفنا بعد كده طبعا ما ا طلعناش على
تقريرهم لكن خرج الاسرائيليون ليقولوا انه
احنا قلمنا اظافر المقاومه وحماس وسوف
تحتاج لسنوات طويله لتعود الى مستوى ما
كانت عليه قبل مايو 21 حصلت عمليه 7
اكتوبر كانت صدمه للاسرائيليين على كل
المستويات واحد هذه المستويات حجم الاسلحه
اللي استطاعت حماس والمقاومه ان تدخ
وتصنعه داخل القطاع مش بس الى مستويات
مايو 2021 ولكن اكبر بكثير الى الحد اللي
بيخلي الاسرائيليين يطرحوا اسئله الاسئله
السلاح ده بيجي منين اما ان هو بيمر تحت
سمع وبصر الاسطول الاسرائيلي اللي بيحص
غزه او ان مصر هي اللي بتبعت هذه الاسلحه
مال هتيجي منين هو مش هتسقط من السماء ان
السماء لا تمطر قنابل ولا
صواريخ
طيب السلام عليكم اخبارك استاذ سيد الله
يحفظك يا اخونا محمد منور شكرا يا مروان
السلام عليكم ما رايك بتصريح ابو عبيده
الذي تعرض فيه للذم لذم الحكومات العربيه
صالح الحربي والله لم اسمعه لكن ماش الحال
يعني ما هو اكيد هو مش هيكون مبسوط انا لم
اسمعه ومن الحكمه ان انا لا اعلق على
تصريح لم اسمعه لكن مفهوم يعني ما هو ممكن
انا بسمح مثلا المرشد الامين العام لحزب
الله الشيخ حسن نصر الله يذم في بعض
الحكومات وخاصه لما يكون الذم عام يعني مش
يعني مش خص بحكومه معينه
فبيكون المقابل او التبعه على هذه
التصريحات مش كبير كل حكومه بتقول مخصنيش
يعني
ا مساء الخير ما هو تفسير موقف الجزيره
القطريه التابعه للحكومه القطريه الداعم
بشده للمقاومه الفلسطينيه والمعادي للكيان
على الرغم من العلاقات القويه بين الحكومه
القطريه والولايات المتحده الداعم الاول
والله انا القصه دي استاذنك في حلقه
بعنوان ماذا تريد قطر هي حلقه قديمه لو
كتبت كده ماذا تريد قطر او لو بحثت حتى
بكلمه قطر على قناه نعرف ان شاء الله تطلع
لك الحلقه من حوالي سنتين اظن ان فيها
تفسير مقبول لكن اجابه سريعه هي قطر خدت
من البدايه سياسه خلاصتها كالاتي انا اهم
دوله عندي في هذا العالم هو الولايات
المتحده
ولكن انا لازم يكون لي دور قوي حتى انا
انا دوله صغيره غنيه لازم احافظ على
استقلالي واستقلال قراري خصوصا من الدول
المجاوره الاقوى مني وعلى راسها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه علشان انا ابقى دوله
احافظ على استقلالي ده تفسيري لازم يكون
لي دور
مهم الدول الكبيره ما تستغناي عنه وعلى
راسهم الولايات المتحده هذا الدور هو انه
قطر تكون على علاقه بكل الجماعات
الاسلاميه اللي في العالم حما الجهاد
طالبان الاخوان المسلمين كل الاسماء تبقى
هي الوسيط اللي من خلاله هذه الجماعات
بتتحدث مع كل القوى الكبرى الولايات
المتحده
وغيرها علشان هي الولايات المتحده في حد
لقطر كوسيط طبعا مع وهي قامت بدور مهم جدا
في الوساطه مع طالبان ودور مهم جدا
للوساطه مع حماس طيب ده يرض الولايات
المتحده ويرض كل دول العالم انا محتاج
دوله تكون هي قناه للتواصل وتاريخيا دول
كتيره لعبت هذا الدور مش مع الجماعات
الاسلاميه بس ولكن مع جماعات
مختلفه لكن علشان خطر تقوم بالدور ده لازم
تكون سياستها مقبوله من هذه الجماعات والا
هذه الجماعات سوف تعتبرها جماعه معاديه
دوله معاديه ليها وعليه الولايات المتحده
مضطره ان تقبل هذا الخطاب الاعلامي المؤيد
للاخوان وطالبان وحماس ولغيرهم علشان قطر
تقدر تستانف دورها ك وسيط مهم جدا في
صراعات حيويه لا تستطيع الولايات المتحده
ان تتواصل مع اطرافها الا من خلال قطر هذا
تقديري لو كانت الاجابه مش واضحه استاذنك
اكتب الي مره اخرى وان شاء الله احاول
اوضح ازيك يا استاذنا الفاضل ده محمد مجدي
لو حماس سلمت كل الرهائن لديها ماذا يمنع
اسرائيل ان تفعل ما يحلو لها وحماس لم
لم يعد لها يعني اوراق تساوم بها طبعا
مافيش اي حاجه تضمن لا احد يمكن ان يثق في
اسرائيل ولكن نقطتين النقطه الاولانيه
انها ان الحرب دي عندما تنتهي سوف تنتهي
بوساطات وتاكيدا يعني لازم هتكون مصر وقطر
والولايات المتحده وكل هذه الدول هيكونوا
وسطاء وهيكون في تعهدات التعهدات دي هتقوم
على اساس ان اسرائيل لن تعود العدوان على
غزه انه اسرائيل
تسمح باعاده اعمار غزه انه اسرائيل تطلق
اسرى الفلسطينيين في مقابل انه واحد اين
3ه منها طبعا اطلاق الاسرى والمختطفين
داخل قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى انه اكيد
اسرائيل سوف تطلب امور تعود بها الى يعني
سياسين الاسرائيليين يعودوا بها الى الراي
العام الاسرائيلي لازم يكون في تنازلات من
حماس من منها مثلا انه يكونوا مش ممثلين
في الحكومه بشكل مباشر ممكن خروج بعض
القيادات من قطع غزه ممكن حاجات كثير
فلازم الحاجه الثانيه بقى نفترض اسرائيل
هي اخلت بكل هذه التعهدات طب وماله ما هي
اسرائيل يعني ما كانتش رحيمه جدا يعني هي
اسرائيل لم تجد حماس طبعا وجود الاسرى قيد
العنف الاسرائيلي بس مش بشكل كبير ما هي
اسرائيل حاولت بتحاول دلوقتي وحاولت في
2021 حاول في 2014
وحاولت في سنوات سابقه لكن هي المقاومه
عصيه على الضرب يعني كل اللي تقدر تعمله
اسرائيل ان هي تضرب وتضرب عمليه تدمير
شامل انما هي عاجزه ان تصل الى المقاومه
بشكل فعال بتكلفه مقبوله لانه المقاومه
اتقنت الصراع مع اسرائيل
وبنت المدينه العظيمه من الانفاق اللي
بتحمي يعني مقاومتها وبالتالي حتى حتى
يعني بقى ان اسرائيل تحارب مش بس شيء مخيف
للمقاومه هو شيء برض مخيف وكابوس لل
للاسرائيليين اذا اردت مثالا خد لبنان
لبنان ما عندهاش شبكه الانفاق دي ولكن بعد
تجربه 2006 وهي تجربه تستحق ان احنا نقف
عليها بقى لبنان كابوس ليه اسرائيل ما
بتروحش تضرب حزب الله لان التكلفه عاليه
جدا عليها
يعني مش عارف في تعب مصري عندنا كده ان
هزار يقول لك ايه شلوه من عليا لاحسن
اموته يعني ما
هو هو يعني مش هو مش بارع قوي في القضاء
على المقاومه بس المشكله في التعهدات
يعني السلام عليكم عليكم السلام محمد جمعه
عليكم السلام محمد شندي السلام عليكم سيد
نتمنى ان تكون هناك حلقه حروب الوكاله في
المنطقه العربيه يعني بكل سرور ان شاء
الله سوريا الى اين سؤال صعب والله يا
حسين الشمري سوريا والله دي عاوزه حلقه بس
يعني اصل سوريا انا
بلاقي
يعني سوريا بقى صراع مجمد
وكل الاطراف استسلمت الى وضع ما حد
يعني ما عادش في حد عنده لا الطاقه ولا
القدره انه يغير في الموازين اللي موجوده
الروس مبسوطين بالوضع القائم الايرانيين
مبسوطين الاتراك ما عندهمش امل في انه
يحصلوا على افضل ما هو عليه المقاومه اضعف
بكثير من الحكومه والرئيس بشار الاسد
فالوضع متجمد وجامد يعني والاطراف تقريبا
قانعه بما لديها لكن ان شاء الله حاضر
نحاول ان احنا باذن الله في اقرب فرصه
نتكلم عن سوريا بشكل
ا بشكل افضل
يعني على فكره انا انا انا انا حطيت
مجموعه من الاختيارات وانتم اخترتوا ان
يكون
موضوع المباشر على ايه بس انا احتراما
للسؤال انا هجاوب بالاسئله اللي بتجيني
يعني فعشان ا نكون واضحين يعني علال بن
عيسى سلام عليكم ما رايك في مستقبل المغرب
الاقتصادي والله يا علال انا كل ما يصلني
وكل ما اسمعه عن
المغرب ايجابي اقتصاديا بالمناسبه هذا لا
يعني
انه ان ان حصاد او الثمار ده واصل لكل
الشعب المغربي ولا في اي دوله علشان انا
عارف ان ممكن ناس يكتبوه يقول لي لا
المعاناه والفقر وال ده موجود في كل حته
او او ده خلل موجود ممكن افهمه لكن كل ما
يصلين من اخبار وانا ما اقدرش اقول ان انا
يعني خبير في الشان المغربي لكن كلها
اخبار ايجابيه وتدعونا للتفاؤل بالوضع
الاقتصادي في
المغرب السلام عليكم بنحب الحلقات ده نزار
اللي بتعملها لوحدك انا انا متشكر يا نزار
انت سالت النقطه ديت واتمنى انه
تسمعوني وتتجاوب معايا تقولي لي ان انا
يعني لكم راي مختلف يعني انا الكلام نزار
بصلني بكل السبل بس احيانا ما بقدرش ارد
عليه ليه انتم بتكتبوا لي في التعليقات
انا بجاوب على اكبر عدد منها لكن بيكون
مثلا انا عندي ضيفي حد من اصدقائي او من
اساتذتي موجود فوق معايا وانتم كاتبين تحت
مش عاوزين فلان انت فده بيكون جارح للضيف
فبمت عن التعليق من اساسه لكن الفكره
اصلاني وعارف ان في ناس اعتدت على اسلوب
انه انه مثلا اخذ قضيه معينه وبعدين
اجهزها بشكل جيد ومبسط وتعرض عليه
بدون اي يعني ببساطه اكتر او بوضوح اكتر
ده كويس وانا ما عملتوش في يعني ده كان
دايما موجود ثم بدانا في حلقه الضيوف ثم
نتيجه احداث غزل الكتيره كتر حجم الضيوف
لكن ان شاء الله هنرجع للاسلوب بس لازم
الضيوف يكونوا موجودين لانه مستحيل لا انا
ولا غيري نكون قادرين على انتاج عدد كبير
من الموضوعات لتغطيه قضايا مختلفه ويكون
لوحده يعني لكم ان تتخيلوا حلقه الانفاق
اللي انا ابهجتني جدا مع الدكتور مثلا
اسامه النحاس انا مش ممكن اكون مهندس او
عندي خبره حد عنده 30 40 سنه في الانفاق
علشان وعلشان انا اسمعها منه واعرضه طب
يعني صعب مش ممكن مثلا يعني في حلقات
كتيره للاساتذه حلقات الدكتور ج عبد
الخالق حلقات الدكتور علي الدين هلال فانا
متفهم وجهه نظركم لكن اكون شاكر انه لو
حطينا المساله بال يعني الاثنين مع بعض
يكونوا مقبولين لانه عندنا قضايا كتير
وانا بكون حريص انه سواء كان ضيف او غير
ضيف تكون في قيمه مضافه في بعض الحلقات
بيجي لي بعض اصدقائي وبيصوروا الحلقات لا
تداع من اساسه لان انا شايف ان الحلقه
مثلا زه جدا سياسيا او منحازه لوجهه نظر
اقتصاديه او ان ماطلعش فيها قيمه مضافه
فما بزعلش من اساسه فعلشان نغطي اكبر عدد
لازم يكون عندنا ضيوف وممكن يكون عندنا
طبعا الحلقات اللي كثر خيركم بتعتقدوا انه
انا ممكن اكون مفيد فيها وبالمناسبه احد
اسباب المباشره النهارده
هو انه ده يكون موجود يعني ان اكون متشرف
بوجودي معاكم مباشره
يعني استاذ سيد ذكرت ح في حلقه سابقه ان
المانيا لديها ثقافه الادخار ولا تفضل
الاقتراض ولكن حينما بحثت وجدت انها من
اعلى دول العالم استدانه نسبه وكرم ارجو
التوضيح لا هو الثقافه موجوده انا يعني
انت بتقول انه الدوله مستد الاول بس هقول
لك
معلومتين
المانيا يقينا عندها ثقافه الادخار على كل
المستويات وفك بل انه انا قريت ويمكن حد
فيكم اللي بيجود اللغه الالمانيه يصحح لي
انا كنتت قريت ولم ادقق في الالمانيه ان
كلمه الدين تعادل في الالمانيه السن او
رزيله او
عيب الحكومه الالمانيه اللي بتابعها يجدها
ان هي بتحج عن مشروعات كثيره ا لانه ده
يعني زياده في الانفاق هي دايما والدستور
بتاعها بيقيد ان العجز في الموازنه العامه
يكون عند نسبه متواضعه جدا تقريبا نص في
فده
اكيد حكايه ان عندها واحده من اعدى نسب
الديون دي عاوزه مراجعه انا مش عارف الرقم
اللي عندك استاذنك تراجعه وانا هراجع لكن
ممكن جدا بعض الحكومات انا عارف الوضع في
اليابان ماعرفش حكايه انه المانيا من اعلى
النسب دي الدين ده دين ايه دين خارجي ولا
ولا ولا دين خارجي ما في دول غنيه زي
اليابان هي شايفه ان ما فيش اي وسيله
لتحريك الشعب على الطلب الا ان الحكومه
تقوم هي بالاستدانه بس بتست دم منين
ياباني بيسلف ياباني عشان يعمل مشروعات
انتاجيه فممكن جدا الحكومه الالمانيه تطرح
سندات السندات ديت بتطرح
ا بشكل امن وتروح تعمل بيه مشروعات وهكذا
لكن تعملها بشكل منضبط ا عموما الاجابه
الادق عشان يكون سؤالك انت طرحت تناقد بس
التناقض ده مبني على انه المانيا واحده من
اكثر دول الع استدانه انا لا اعلم هذه
المعلومه واحتاج اراجعها وبعد مراجعتها
تكون الاجابه ادق وانت كمان تكون دققت ولو
وصلت لحاجه ابعت لي على الفيسبوك ممكن
تبعت لي رساله على المسنجر يعني هل مصر
اضعف في اضعف اوقاتها سياسيا اعتقد اه
اعتقد ان مصر في من الاوقات اللي هي
بتعاني فيه من ضعف سياسي لانه انت علشان
يكون عندك حريه التصرف والقرار لازم تكون
انت لازم تكون بتتوفر مجموعه من الشروط من
بين هذه الشروط هي ان يكون الموقف
الاقتصادي صلب فاذا كنت انت نسبه الدين
عندك عاليه جدا اذا كنت انت في حاجه الى
كل دول الجوار والقوى الكبرى في العالم
لمساعدتك في تجاوز ازمتك الاقتصاديه فانت
لا تستطيع ان تكون صداميه ده واحد اثنين
ان مصر مش بتواجه ازمه واحده مصر بتواجه
مجموعه كبيره من الازمات موضوع السد
العالي ازمه منفجره اسف سد النهضه ازمه
منفجره الحكومه بتقول لنا من وقت للتاني
انا ياست بس ما بتقول لناش حل الوضع في
السودان ماساوي للسودانيين طبعا ولكن
للدول السبع اللي بتجور مصر ومنهم اللي
بتجور السودان ومنهم مصر الوضع في اليمن
خطير جدا مش على اليمنيين والسعوديين ده
مفهوم ولكن ايضا على المصريين لان اي
تاثير على الملاحه في باب المنب يعني
تاثير على اهم مورد للعمله الصعبه في مصر
او واحد من اهم الموارد وهو صد النهضه
عندها طبعا المشكله في ليبيا عندها
المشكله في غزه فطبعا اه نعم الاجابه نعم
تقدير يعني مستقبل اليمن ده اخونا عليه
مستقبل اليمن يا اخونا في عندنا احتمالين
او انا اقدر اقول لك انه الوضع اللي موجود
في اليمن لا ليه حل سياسي ولا ليه حل
عسكري ليه حل من عند ربنا مافيش حل عسكري
كريي جون
بيضحك انا معايا جون وايمن النهارده معايا
بيساعدوني
سميلي مافيش حل عسكري لانه واضح ان هم
جربوا من 2015 لغايه دلوقتي ان يضربوا
الحوثي ومش عارفين ليه قصه ممكن نتكلم
فيها لكن مين اللي كان بيضرب السعوديه بكل
ما لديها من اسلحه متطوره واليمن وكل
الدول اللي دعمتهم منهم الولايات المتحده
ومنهم بريطانيا كل دول
دعموا ماقدروش ف ودلوقتي هي هي بتعمل اللي
بتعمله ده فيب في مديق باب المندب وكل
اللي بتعمله الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ودول حلف شمال الاطلسي ودول الجوار ان هم
يتعرضوا للصواريخ ويسقطها دون ان يبادروا
بالعدوان على الحوثي طب لماذا ما هو اولا
جربه من 2015 عشان يعملوا حرب ويشيلوا
فيها قدرات الحوثيين عاوزين عمليه تستمر
شهور او سنه طيب وخلال السنه دي انا بقول
يعني فتره طويله
طب وخلال السنه ديت عليهم ان ينتظروا
التالي الاف الدرونز والصواريخ اللي ه
تستهدف الاساطيل الامريكيه والبريطانيه
ودول المنطقه اللي اللي بتهاجم الحوثييين
عليهم ان ينتظروا الاف من الدرونز
والصواريخ اللي هتشل مضيق باب المندب
والتجاره الدوليه عليهم ان ينتظروا صواريخ
لا حصره لها بيصنعوها داخل اليمن الان
عشان تضرب كل المنشات البتروليه والحيويه
في دول الجوار والقواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه التكل فه كبيره جدا وما فيش حل
سياسي ليه مافيش حل سياسي لانه الحل
السياسي معناها ان الاطراف تقعد وكل واحد
ويبقى فيه انتخابات مثلا او يكون فيه وكل
قوى يمنيه تمثل
ب قبل ما اتكلم على الحل سياسي كمان انه
في وجود القوه العسكريه ديت هي القوه
الاقوى في اليمن ومسيطره على معظم شمال
اليمن في مقابل قوى غير متجانسه بتمثل
القسم المشترك الوحيد بينها ان هم ضد
الحوتي لكن في ما بينه خلافات كبيره
والقوى الابرز بينهم اللي عندها تصور واضح
الانفصال
بالجنوب وفي خلافات بين الدول الحلفاء
نفسهم السعوديه والامارات وغيرهم على
مستقبل اليمن تصورات مختلفه عشان يبقى في
حل سياسي لازم الناس دول يعودوا على
ترابيزه يتفاوضوا التفاوض على الترابيزه
او المائده او الطويله بيعكس القوه
الحقيقيه على الارض طب ما القوه الحقيقيه
موجوده في يد
الحوثي طيب واذا قبلت الدول بالوضع الحالي
كل كل العالم خسران بصراحه يعني السعوديين
ودول الخليج
و السعوديين اكثر لان هم على جنوب
السعوديه معناه ان هم يكونوا تحت رحمه
الحوثيين اذا رضيت عنهم خلاص ح حدث
استقرار واذا
غضبت اشعلت الحدود واشعلت المنطقه ا اليمن
نفسها خسرانه مع وافر الاحترام لجماعه
الحوثي وانصار الله انا طبعا يعني ما
اقدرش ان انا الا ان اكون متعاطفا مع اي
جماعه تتصدى لاسرائيل دي قناعتي يعني لا
الزم الناس بها عاطفيا هذا يسرني يعني بس
ده يصر عشرات ومئات الملايين في العالم
فهي اكتسبت شعبيه لكن انا عقليا وعلى
المستوى المنطقي يعني ان مستقبل اليمن في
ظل جماعه بتؤمن
بال ا بالخلافه لاهل البيت
وهذه جماعه لا مكان لها في القرن ال 21 مع
وافر الاحترا
يعني ان ده يكون هو المستقبل اليمن
ومستقبل المنطقه ده مساله تقلق الجميع
تقلق اليمن تضر اليمن تضر دول المنطقه ولو
يعني مش عاوز اطول اكتر من كده علشان ما
افرش عليكم موضوع قد لا يكون من
اهتماماتكم ما هو تعليقك على دعم الامارات
للدعم السريع ولماذا لا تتعرض للعقوبات
يوسف ما هو يا يوسف ما هي الامارات ما
بتقولش انا بدعم الدعم السريع انما
الامارات عندها علاقات
يعني
بمحمد بالفريق حمدتي وهو شركته موجوده
هناك او بعضها موجود في الامارات فهي ما
بتقولش وبعدين هو العالم كله بيبقى فيه
نوع من التواطئ السودان ليست اولويه على
الدول
الكبيره ليه مش اولويه هم انشغلوا
باوكرانيا ثم انشغلوا بغزه وانشغلوا
بالانتخابات اللي هي
بتقترب يعني هي الحرب اندلعت في ابريل في
ابريل ده اللي هو السنه اللي فاتت فاضل
حوالي مان شهور على بدايه 2024 لما بدات
الحرب حكومات كتيره كانت بتجهز نفسها
للانتخابات اللي جايه في 24 24 ده عام
انتخابات يعني عدد ضخم جدا من الانتخابات
في دول العالم في الحكومات بتقول انا
عاوزه اهل نفسي ان انا اخرج من النزاعات
وان جنود يكونوا بره استعدادا للتهدئه
استعدادا لفوزي في الانتخاب ثم ان مصالح
الدول الكبيره مش ممسوسه يعني مثلا لو انه
بلد زي روسيا عاوزه ذهب وعاوزه كذا خلاص
موجوده والقوه بتحمي مصالحها لو ان
الولايات المتحده عندها
مصالح في دوله ما حتى في ظل الفوضى ما
بتتاثر
كتير ف ماهش اولويه
يعني زي التواطؤ اللي انت بتقول عليه اذا
ثبت اذا ثبت انه الامارات بتلعب دور مقلق
يعني
انا يعني بتحفظ على ده انا مش متاكد منه
تماما يعني مش عارف ان هي مختلفه عن بقيه
دول العالم في ده كل دوله بتلعب مصالحها
مش الامارات وحدها فدول العالم سايبه ملف
السودان كله
مهملا يعني لو على كلامك كده لو كانت
الامارات بتلعب هذا الدور مثلا في دعم
الروس ما كانش الاكان ابدا سكته يعني او
في دعم حماس
مثلا ما رايك في دخول البحرين في التحالف
اي تحالف يا صديقي السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله عليكم السلام هل الدول العربيه
مستفيده من الحرب في اسرائيل هتستفيد ايه
الدول العربيه متضرره طبعا يعني ماذا
تستفيد الدول العربيه يا اخونا شرف متى
تعيش في ده انت بس مش عاوز يعني الاجابه
لا مش هتستفيد يعني مصر هتستفيد ايه ان هي
عرضت نفسها لكل هذا الضغط الاقتصادي
والسياسي السعوديه الحرب تقريبا افسدت
مخططاتها الامارات البحرين تعرضوا لاحراج
جدا بان هم يكونوا على علاقه مع دوله
بترتب جرائم حرب الولايات المتحده
نفسها يعني سمعتها في الارض كل الدول
متضرره يعني الاردن
طبعا متى نعيش في ع متعدد
الاقطاب والله هو حلم بدات بوادره الان
بانه بعد ما كانت السلطه مطلقه للولايات
المتحده على دول العالم من بعد 91 الان
عالم جديد بيتشكل لكن لم يكتمل بعد نامل
ذلك يعني لماذا سلام سلام استاذ سيد ماذا
عن التفاوت الطبقي الهائل بالمجتمع المصري
والله يا اياد التفاوت الطبقي الهائل قصدك
ال
تفاوت الدخول يعني اكتر الطبقي يمكن
التعبير يكون
اقل يعني الانسب التفاوت الكبير في الدخول
طبعا ده قصه قديمه موجوده ولكن هذا ينطبق
تقريبا على معظم دول العالم تفاوت خطير
جدا في الدول الراسماليه الديمقراطيه
والدول الغير ديمقراطيه زينا دايما مجتمع
الوا في الم بيملك
تقريبا يعني معظم ثروات اي بلد بيعيشوا
فيها وزي ما مش فاكر كان مين اللي بيقول
لو علم الفقراء كم يعيش الاغنياء وكما
يملكون يعني لا نزلوا الى الشوارع يعني
محتاجين التفاوت هائل جدا جدا جدا وايلك
الى تقارير منظمه اوكسفام هي ما بتقولش
حاجات نادره ولكن مكرسه نفسها لفكره رصد
هذا
التفاوت من ضمن التشبيهات اللي كانت
بتقولها ان اتوبيس واحد يضم من 70 الى 100
شخص في اتوبيس واحد دول ممكن دول بيملكه
قد ما بتملك نصف الكره الارضيه كلها يعني
تجيب نصف الكره الارضيه 4 مليار وتشوف
مقدراتهم معاهم كام هتلاقي ان الرب مليار
بني ادم دول ما يملكوه قد ما يملكوا
الاتوبيس اللي فيه مثلا 100 ملياردير ولا
حاجه بس في دول افضل من دول يعني انت مثلا
تروح لدوله فتجد ان انت مثلا في بلد زي
المانيا طبعا التفاوت موجود والاثرياء
موجودين وكله بس ممكن تلاقي ان الحد
الادنى موجود في دوله راس ماليه ان
التعليم مجانا وجيد انه تلاقي ان التامين
الصحي بديهي للمريض وغير المريض حتى في
دول راسماليه ماهش رحيمه قوي زي بريطانيا
انه انت معاك فلوس معكش فلوس انت بتتعالج
غير النظام مثلا في الولايات المتحده او
غير النظا نظام في دول عندنا في دول
المنطقه انه لا اللي بيخفف من الشعور في
مصر ودول انيه ان
الناس بيترا الثقافه الناس بتساعد
بعض لماذا اصبحت سمعه الامارات سيئه وهل
ما يشاع عنها صحيح لا انا ما عنديش هذه
المعلومه يا صديقي لا اعلم ان الامارات
سيئه السمعه الامارات دوله اصل الكلمه
يعني مفتوحه وماعرفش ايه هو الذي يشع عشان
اقول ان هو صحيح ولا لا فلو دققت لي وقلت
لي ماذا تقصد يمكن ان يكون الرد معقول
يعني اشتقنا لحلقتك
منفردا تعرض وجهه نظرك في الكثير من
الامور ربنا يخليك يا روبرت حاضر احنا ان
شاء الله لو كان المباشر والله انا كنت
شايف المباشر فكره لطيفه يعني بس انا اللي
عطلن على المباشر مجموعه من الاسباب واحده
منها ان فعلا بقى المكتب اللي انا موجود
فيه ده في الحي اللي احنا موجودين فيه
احنا في جدول تخفيف احمال بتنقطع
الكهرباء تقريبا في المعاد اللي انا كنت
بعمل فيه من مانيه ل 10 حاجه زي كده فبعد
فتره قلنا طيب ما لا يدرك كله وده كان
معاد مناسب لكل الناس في الدول المختلفه
يعني ففكرت في فكره الساعه 7عه ديت و
بالمناسبه لو قطع علينا النور يعني
اعذرونا
يعني لكن ده كان واحد من الاسباب لو كان
ده مفيد قولوي وان شاء الله نحاول نلتقي
مثلا ساعه اسبوعيا ولا حاجه ان شاء
الله
هل هناك فرصه للحل السلمي في
السودان هل هل في فرصه ممكن لكن هتبقى
صعبه بتكلفه عاليه مش منتظر ان هي تكون
بكره ولا بعده ليه لان انا الناس بتلج الى
السلام امتى او الى التفاوض لما يكون فقد
الامل في الحسم العسكري الاثنين لان لو
واحد فقد الامل والثاني واثق اللي واثق لن
يعني لن يلجا الى المفاوضات ما انا واثق
من النصر يبقى ليه بعد انا ما حرت ثمان
شهور واقدر افرض شروطي على المهزوم الجع
لماده المفاوضات ليه ولكن لازم الاثنين
يسوا حتى الان الاثنين غير يائسين الاثنين
عندهم امل في الحسم
العسكري يؤسفني انه كده يعني ان الوضع في
السودان وده عاوز له اكتر من حلقه احنا
بنتكلم على سيناريو وتقسيم للسودان مش
لازم تقسيم يعني بانه دوله تعلن
يعني تعلن قيامها زي جنوب السودان ولا زي
تيمور الشرقيه ولا لا ولكن ممكن كده زي زي
وضع في ليبيا ادي الشرق كده دوله لوحدها
عنده حكومه وعنده جيش وعنده كذا وكذلك
الغرب عنده ويتعايش على الوضع اللي هم
يعني بقاء الوضع على ما هو عليه قد يكون
هو هو ده ولكن ده هيكون ليه مقاسي عنيفه
جدا جدا جدا على السودان اللي هو بيعاني
من سنين السودان بيعاني من 58 لكن بيعاني
اكتر من 89 وسنه
ف
يعني للاسف الوضع في السودان
مخيف استاذ هل تتوقع لقاء مباشر بين حمدتي
والبرهان حتى لو يتقابلوا هل ممكن يحله
انا اشك في هذا زي نفس السبب اللي انا
بقول عليه اللي انا خايف منه ما هو اسوا
يعني اللي جاي احنا عندنا واضح
انه الدعم السريع بيتقدم عسكريا اكثر مما
توقع الكثيرون وبيزيد تقدمه العسكري ووضع
الجيش في الزاويه والجيش دلوقتي موجود
خارج العاصمه قياداته موجوده في بور سودان
اللي انا قلان منه انه مش بس الصراع وده
اصلا شيء مخيف ان يبقى فيه تقسيم ويبقى
لان الجيش تقريبا بيسيطر اكثر على الشرق
وشرق النيل يعني
وال الدعم السريع بيسيطر اكثر على الغرب
واجزاء واسعه من الخرطوم انا الان مع طول
امد الصراع انه الاطراف دي تنقسم على
نفسها ويبقى عندنا بدل ما انا عندي قوتين
رئيسيتين الى حد كبير يكون عندي عده قوى
متنحه كل منها يحارب الاخر اتمنى طبعا ماك
كونش الوضع كده لكن ده هو اللي وضع على
الارض ليه
منظمه اوبك ناجحه بمعنى ان المنط المنظمه
خفضت الانتاج مثلا
بكذا بكذا الدول خارج المنظمه مستفيده
معناها لم تخفض انتاجها بربما تزيده لا
عبد الرحمن معلش مش فاهم انا فاهم انت
بتقول المنظمه ناجحه ا بمعنى انها خفرت
انتاج فهمه ا بكده الدول خارج المنظمه
مستفيده معناها لم تخفض انتاجها انا
سامحني مش فاهم السؤال لكن انا ممكن
استنتج منظمه الاوبك هي منظمه فكرتها
الاساسيه ان تحافظ على مصالح الدول
المنتجه
للنفط هدفها انه البترول لا يكون غالي جدا
بحيث انه ده ؤدي الى ما هو لو البترول زي
مثلا دول البترول تتمنى نظريا نظريا لو
برميل البترول بقى ب 1000 دولار بس ده
كلام في يعني في المطلق هي عارفه ان في
سعر معين يبقى ممتاز ليها وليكن مثلا 90
دولار للبرميل هي بتحسبها كده لو اكتر من
90 او اكت من 100 اي رقم يعني لو اكت ما
يفيدها ليه ما يفيدها لانه هيبقى غالي جدا
هدي الى حاجتين سيئتين الحاجه الاولانيه
انه هدي الارتفاع تكاليف الانتاج في
العالم كله فيؤدي الى
ا يعني تضخم يؤدي الى مشاكل اقتصاديه يؤدي
الى خروج شركات كتيره بره بره السوق
وبالتالي قل الطلب عن البترول فده ما
تحبوش طيب ولو قل عن 90 هي ده بيكون
بالنسبه لها مش مجدي هي محتاجه الرقم ده
يغطي تكاليف انتاجها ويصرف على كل
احتياجاتها الاقتصاديه خصوصا ان معظم دول
اوبك دخلها الرئيسي من البترول ا بشكل
رئيسي علشان تحقق الرقم ده هي مضطره ان هي
تتدخل في اداره السوق بان هي تقلل الانتاج
بحيث ان هي لما السعر بينخ فض علىشان ترفع
السعر او
ا تزود الانتاج علشان تخفض السعر عند
السعر التوازني اللي براه لو في دول
استفادت من خارج منظمه اوبك من ذلك ما
يضرها لو في دول
تضررت من منظمه اوبك طالما هي بتتكلم على
سعر توازني مش سعر جامح برض مش مؤثر في
كده كتير
يعني سؤال كيف تقبل مصر الواقع تقلب مصر
الواقع تقلب مصر الواقع حولها لمصلحتها ده
محتاجه عبقري عشان يعمل كده اصر محتاجه
تعيد النظر في امور كثيره محتاجه تعيد
النظر في امور كثيره والتغيير يبدا
بالسياسه وقفه واسعه
ومتان الوقفه ديت تقول انه لازم يكون في
مشاركه اكبر في صنع القرار ده مهم جدا
لازم نعيد النظر في كثير من القرارات التي
يعني ثبت انها غير مجديه لازم يبدا اعاده
بناء الاقتصاد المصري بشكل يليق بدوله هي
الاكبر عددا على الاقل ولما اقول اكبر
عددا ده شيء مؤلم لي لان مصر ما كانش
المفروض ابدا انها توصف بانها الدوله
الاكبر عددا مصر محتاجه في تساؤلات عشرات
الاسئله مطروحه تقريبا مش عاوز اقول من
ساعه ما اتولدت من ساعه ما اتولدت كان في
حرب وفي كذا و لكن على الاقل من سنوات
طويله جدا الملف التقدم المصري في الملف
الاقتصادي اللي هو ام المشكلات متواضع جدا
جدا جدا
جدا اصلاحه عاوز صبر وعاوز اناه لكن عاوز
اراده قبل يعني ان احنا ناخد وقت طويل
مفهوم بس نبدا
ف يعني بدون اصلاح الملف الاقتصادي اولا
هيبقى كل القضايا الاخرى الحديث عنها
هامشي لانه حتى دورك في السياسات الخارجيه
مرتبط بقدراتك الاقتصاديه ف حل الاقتصاد
حل الاقتصاد مش ممكن يبقى فعال الا بحلول
سياسيه يعني حلول سياسيه ما انت لما تجيب
النهارده مثلا انت لما يكون في مناخ سياسي
ا مستقر وشفاف وعندنا انتخابات محليه مثلا
الناس كلهم بتتكلموا على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ما لهاش الكلام على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه خلينا نتكلم عن انتخابات محليه
انتخابات نقابات انتخابات انديه دي يكون
فيها نسبه حريه كتيره والناس تاتي بمن
تعتقد انه مناسب ولما يجي الشخص ده انه
يشتغل محتاج انه يعمل لصالح الناس لانه
عارف ان هو لاث سنين ولا اربع سنين ولا
خمس سنين وممكن يمشي وتبقى في فاعليه في
المجتمع اكتر ويكون في برلمان ممثل لكل
الناس وهكذا يعني ده ممكن يعمل فاعليه
ويكون مناسب يعني
اكتر ويتم محاسبه المسؤولين في اماكنهم عن
اي
تقصير ما هو مستقبل الصراع في اوكرانيا
اذا انتصرت روسيا كما هو متوقع هل تتوسع
الحرب الى دول اخرى وخاصه بولندا ودول
البلطيق التي تحوي اقليات روسيه والله كل
السنارات ورده يا صديقنا لكن مستقبل
الصراع في اوكرانيا الان النهارده لو
بنتكلم على 27 ديسمبر
2023 يعني احنا افضل وصف للحرب ان هي
استيل ميت يعني مافيش حراك بس مافيش حراك
دي كلمه تبدو لطيفه يعني مع ذلك ان
القوتين متكافئتين لا هم مش متكافئتين هم
الروس سيطروا مسيطرين طبعا
على شبه جزيره القرم ده من 2014 وفشلت
محاولات اوكرانيا وكل دول الغرب في تغيير
هذا الوضع لكن كمان فشل وفي تغيير وضع
سيطره روسيا
على المناطق الاربعه الاخرى اللي هي بتمثل
تقريبا كده مع شبه جزيره القرم تقريبا 20
في من مساحه اوكرانيا
وفشلت الحمله المضاده بكل الدعم الغربي
اللي هو بعشرات المليارات في تغيير هذا
الوضع
والاسوا من كده بالنسبه لاوكرانيا انه
مادش عندهم امل كبير او الطاقه او
المومنتم ان هم يكملوا ما انا ممكن اكون
اوكي ان انا يحصل تكافؤ مع دوله عظمى زي
روسيا ماشي بس هو مش ماشي قوي لان هي
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا دوله مهمه دوله قويه
قبل الحرب يعني احنا بس بنقول دوله اصغر
مقارنه بروسيا لكن هي بالاضافه الى
امكانياتها
وقدراتها هي مدعومه من 50 دوله يعني بقناه
الولايات المتحده فيكون ان يحصل هذا
الجمود مش جيد ليها لكن الاخطر انه بقى
هي على لسان جنرالات ما عندناش القدره ان
احنا نعمل اكتر من كده لانه احنا استنفذنا
اكبر عدد ممكن ان نجن الخسائر اكبر من
قدرتنا على التعويض مش بس في الذخائر
ولكن ولا في التمويل اللي بدا الدول
الحليفه متردده في ان هي تدعم او تستمر في
دعم اوكرانيا بي ولكن على مستوى الافراد
واحد
مسؤولين اوكران وده مش السر يعني ده قالوه
عده مرات حتى لو وفرت الولايات
المتحده لنا التمويل والاسلحه ليس لدينا
افراد قادرين على استخدام هذا السلاح بعد
حوالي ل سنتين من الحرب
اا هل سيقبل الاطراف الداخليه اليمنيه
الحوثي زعيما لليمن محمد لا مش هيقبل
زعيما لليمن لكنه هيقبل بوجوده في معظم
مناطق
الشمال هم تقريبا سلموا بذلك اصل مين اللي
هيقبل في قوه مؤثره موجوده في المجلس
الرئاسي اللي هو بيمثل ما يسمى بالحكومه
الشرعيه
ما هو مستقرين هم عاوزين يستقلوا بالجنوب
اساسا في كان عاوز يستقل بالجنوب كل اللي
يهمه ان يامن
يعني عدوان الحوثيين عليهم وما اعتقدش ان
الحوثيين في الوقت الحالي ممكن يفكروا في
ده في الوقت الحالي يعني لشهور او لعده
سنوات او وبالتالي ممكن يقبلوا وجوده في
اليمن اليمن الشماليه لو حد من اليمنيين
بيتابعني يقوللي ايه السر يعني ان هم
بيسموا اليمن الشماليه واليمن الجنوبيه
بينما التسميه المنطقيه اليمن الشرقيه
واليمن الغربيه هي مش مش ماشيه كده يعني
مجرد سؤال يعني
ا يبدو ان ليه علاقه بالتاريخ بالتطور
التاريخي يعني شكرا جزيلا لمحتواه يا فندم
باكينام ربنا باكينام ربنا يخليكي باكينام
شكرا جزيلا ما رايك في النفيسي لا اعلمه
يا اخي لا مش عارف اي نفيسي اذا كنت
بتتكلم في كاتب دايما بيكتب ا عن الشان
الشيعي وانا مش متخصص في هذه الامور اذا
كان ده قصدك يعني اتكلم عن فتح معبر رفح
والله لا اعلم عنه شيئ يا احمد يعني ايه
يعني ايه المشكله في فتح المعبر تقصد من
يعني بتدخل فييه كميات كبيره ولا لا ولا
كذا يعني وضح لي ماذا
تقصد استاذ سيد ممكن حلقه عن الدوله
العربيه الوكيله للسياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه لو سمحت ما لم افهم السؤال يا
صديقي اتش اي او اتش اي نا لم افهم السؤال
سامحني يعني عبد الرحمن حينما ننظر في
اقتصادات بعض الدول مثل
الصين التي كانت في 2020 حجم اقتصاد 14
تريليون وفي 2021 17
تريليون الزياده 25% وليس الارقام المعلنه
7%
ا ما هو السؤال يا عبد الرحمن
ا انت بتقول كلام عميق عبد الرحمن انا مش
عارف ايه السؤال يعني اذا كان حد عمل
البرنج غلط خلاص مافيش مشكله يعني هي
الارقام زي ما انت بتقول كده كانت النسبه
14 تريليون ثم قفزت الى 17 فلو حد حسب
النسبه غلط خلاص يعني
غلطانين ازدواجيه المعايير انا طبعا ما
حسبتهاش على الكالكوليتر بس يعني احسبها
باي طريقه وهتكون النسبه تحصيل حاصل يعني
ازدواجيه المعايير ده دكتور نايف ازدواجيه
المعايير الغربيه لكه وقت مواجهه المملكه
للحوثيين هو ايه بقى الازدواجيه يعني انا
لا اشاركك يا صديقي لو تقصد انه الغرب كان
هو الغرب بصفه
عامه حكايه عنده ازدواجيه المعايير ديت دي
مش تهمه ده هو كده يعني يعني دي حاجه مش
غريبه فكلمه الزواجات المعير كلمه لطيفه
يعني معظم الدول الغربيه وبالذات الدول
الكبيره دول منافقه يعني وبالذات زعيم
العالم الحر اذا كان تعبير العالم الحر
دقيق بس هم بيحبوا يشيروا الى انفسهم الى
العالم الحر الولايات المتحده باتت منذ
سنوات هي دوله منافقه بامتياز تفتقد الى
اي جداره اخلاقيه ن تدي للناس دروس انا
ممكن اقول ده بالدليل واحد انين تلاه اعه
مش كلام انشائي يعني فلو هي عندها معايير
مزدوجه مع السعوديه مفهوم بس فيما يتعلق
باليمن هي العمليه انا مش شايف ان
هي معايير مزدوجه عندهم مصالح يعني هم
عندهم مصالح مع السعوديه فوافقوا على
عمليه ودعموا السعوديه وادوها اسلحه
وادوها دخير بعد كده وجدوا انه استمرار
الحرب بيعمل لهم احراج فتيجي اداره تانيه
تقول لهم من فضلكم توقفوا عن الحرب انما
ما عملوش حاجه كتيره يعني توقفوا عن بيع
بعض الاسلحه ثم عادوا اعطوا الاسلحه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه و ماشي انتقاد
السعوديين ده من مين حاجه دايما مرتبطه
ب الانتخابات الحملات الانتخابيه بعض
اعضاء الكونجرس ده بديهي جدا لازم ينتقد
السعوديه لانه الثقافه مختلفه خالص وفي
حلقه انا اظن اتكلمنا عن فيها كده عن
نوايا بايدن للسعوديه فيها بتكلم عن ليه
سبب الجفوه وعدم الحب من الامريكان في
المطلق يعني مش واحد قاعد في الكرسي عضو
كونجرس ومرشح لحمله انتخابيه لازم ينتقد
السعوديه
لانه المسافه كبيره قوي في الثقافه
يعني وحش تنا حلقات اللايف يا استاذ سيد
ربنا يخليك يا ادهم عايزين حلقه مطوله عن
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وعد
حاضر اتمنى ان اراك باستمرار لانك من
الاشخاص الذين يعطوني املا في الاعلام
العربي والمصري خصوصا وانا بفتح اليوتيوب
خاصه لك فقط ربنا يخليك ابراهيم
والله يعني ام تشد يعني شكرا جزيلا كتر
الف
خيرك هل عند مصر حل اخر مع اثيوبيا سو
الحرب
مش عارف مش عارف اصل انا موضوع اثيوبيا ده
انا انا ضللت وخدعت فيه يعني بصراحه يعني
انا لازم اكون امين وقلت انا عندي خبره
كبيره كصحفي ومع ذلك انا عدد من المصادر
اللي انا كنت بثق فيها تماما طول الوقت
كانت بتديني معلومات وانا واثق من جدارتهم
ولكن يبدو ان هم مت كانوا متفائلين اكتر
من اللازم يبدو انه كان عندهم اي اغراض
تانيه ولكن انا الان مش انا ما دلوقتي مش
انا انا وغيري لان الحكومه المصريه قالت
خلاص مافيش مفاوضات تاني ولم نصل الى حال
فده لم يعد سرا انما قبل كده كان سر
فانا مش عارف ايه الحل بس هو مساله الحرب
دي مساله صعبه
وتوابعها كتيره وابسط تابع ليها يعني انه
دول كتيره افريقيه انت تحب تبقى علاقتك
بها قويه لن تبارك ولن تؤيد ولن تسعد بانك
انت توجه دوله لاثيوبيا ضربه
لابيا فمش عارف اذا تعثرت المفاوضات وصعبه
الحرب يكون الحل ايه هل الامر اصبح خلاص
امر
واقع استاذ سيد هل تتوقع لقاء مباشر بين
حمتي
والبرهان ليس لدي توقع لا اعلم ليس لدي
هذا القدر من المعلومات بالتفاصيل اللي
بتحكم الاعتبارات اللي بتحكم الطرفين ولكن
ما انا واثق منه ان سواء التقوا ام لم
يلتقوا لا يوجد حل سريع وجيد للسودانيين
للاسف الشديد يعني انت بتتكلم على بلد 46
مليون ومساحته قد مصر مرتين يعني 1.9 من
مليون كيلو متر مربع 7 مليون منهم الكلام
ده التقديرات من شهر تركوا منازلهم اما
لولايات اخرى يا اما الى خارج السودان
ويترك ديت مش يعني ان هو راح يسافر في
المصرف يعني يعني طلع بما يملك
من ممتلكات وسيطه وساب ممتلكاته وساب عمله
وساب مدارس ولاده
ماساه بتتكلم على 19 مليون طفل ولا تلميذ
سوداني سواء في المدرسه او الجامعه تركوا
مدارسهم انت بتتكلم تقديرات منظمه الصحه
العالميه سب 8 مليون اصابتهم امراض معديه
خطيره زي الكوليرا انت بتتكلم على اوضاع
خطيره
جدا في تقديرات لبعض الاقتصاديين
السودانيين عن اول ثلاث شهور ان البنيه
التحت تضررت بحوالي 49 مليار دولار طبعا
دي مجرد تقديرات ممكن تبقى اكتر ممكن تبقى
اقل انما ارقام مهوله السودان نفسه قبل ما
يدخل الحرب دي كان دوله فقيره رغم كل
امكانياته كنا بنتكلم على للت للث الشعب
السوداني وعاني من جوع يعني الناس مش
قادره تحصل على
احتياجاتها فتخيل ماذا فعلت هذه الحرب
يعني سؤال ماذا يحدث اذا
ا والله ما مقصود ده انا عملت كده طارت كل
يعني عشان حد بيفتكر ان انا بطنه لكن انا
بيته لي يعني هي اسئله نطت كده كتير لكن
ماذا يحدث تقريبا اذا حمت تولى السلطه لا
ما
ينفعش السيد حمتي يتولى السلطه
لانه دوليا صعب انه رجل بخلفيته هو مطارد
بجرائم حرب هو وكثيرا من
من
يعني اصدقائه او داعميه صعب ولكن هو ممكن
يبقى جزء من
معادله يظل مؤثر الى ان تتغير موازين
القوه لكن ان يكون رئيسا او زعيما للسودان
بخلفيته
وكونوا انه جاء من من الشيات جنجويد على
ما اذكر
وتورته في جرائم حرب مشهود بها صعب جدا
يعني انا بحاول ارجع للسؤال تاني هو هرب
السؤال فانا رجعت يعني اول الصفحه السلام
عليكم استاذ سيد هل تعتقد ان هناك حاله
عداء حقيقيه بين ايران واسرائيل ام ان
هناك تبادل ادوار
و يعني وان الاتنين يعني بينسوا مع بعض
عشان يحكموا المنطقه انا قلت رايي في
القصه دي كثيرا يا اخونا
بور ولكن اكرره مره اخرى بس بعد ما ايمن
يقول لي هل القطعت الكهرباء واحنا عايشين
على جهاز التنفس الصناعي ولا
لا روح يا ايمن انا في تقديري لا العداء
كبير بين ايران وبين
اسرائيل قطعا اسرائيل تتمنى لو تختفي
ايران قطعا ايران بتعتقد ان اسرائيل دوله
يعني هي هي حليف الشيطان الاكبر وهي شيطان
مثل الولايات المتحده انما اللي بتقوله ده
لان الثنين مدركين ان كل طرف طرف قوي
فممكن يتعلموا ان هم يتاقلم على تواجد كل
منهما في نفس المنطقه ده بيحصل احنا بنقسم
مناطق نفوذ يعني انا عارفه ان اسرائيل
عارفه ان دي منط شيء حساس جدا بالنسبه
لايران فتتقاضى عنه وهي تدرك ان دي مساله
هدي الى غضب كبير جدا في اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده فتغ الطرف ده مفهوم ده
راي
يعني اذا تمادت واثرت اسرائيل على خرق
اتفاقيه فيلادلفيا وضرب الحدود ده الدكتور
علي ابراهيم دكتور علي رحيم
على خرق اتفاقيه فيلادلفيا وضرب الحدود
وتفجير واغراق الانفاق ودفع اهالي غزه نحو
مصر والى اي مدى يمكن ان تصل اه يعني رد
فعل مصر والله برض ده عا زي بتاع اثيوبيا
بس انا بتال الصوره اوضح انا بس عاوز اوضح
حاجه بالنسبه لقصه ممر فيلادلفيا
لانه يعني القصه ابسط كتير من الناس بتسال
عليه كانه لغز كبير يعني هي بعد
60 سيناء احتلت سيناء اسرائيل احتلت سيناء
وطبعا كانت
بتحتلم اللي كانت بتحكمها مصر قبل 67
نيابه عن الشعب الفلسطيني زي ما كانت كده
بعد 48 يعني الاردن بتحكم الضفه وبما انه
هي اعتقدت كده ان سينا كده البلد بلد
ابوهم فما كانتش حريصه قوي على
وضع خط عازل بين الحدود المصريه
و غز هي كانت بتامل ان الاحتلال يستمر لما
اجبرت على الانسحاب سنه
82 كان لازم ان هي تعمل خط فاصل او منطقه
عزله بين القوات المصريه وما
بين قوات
الاحتلال فهنا نشا فكره اللي
هو ممر فيلادلفيا او طريق فيلادلفيا او
اظن بيسموه احيانا معبر صلاح الدين او ممر
صلاح الدين فهي منطقه عازله انسحبت القوات
الاسرائيليه سنه خه 2005 وبالتالي
يعني المنطقه العازله دي بالنسبه لها كانت
مهمه لحاجه تانيه انها طلبت من مصر طب انا
هنسحب بس انت اضمني لي ان انت ه تسيطري
على حدودك تماما بحيث ان ما يكونش لا في
جريمه منظمه ولا ارهاب ولا انفاق ولا
مقاومه طب ومصر تعمل كده ليه محبه في
اسرائيل لا ما هي مصر من مصلحتها ان هي
مافيش اي عمليه تنطلق من حدودها تجاه اي
دوله هي على علاقه بيه والا الدوله دي ه
يعني هترد
بالمثل فبالتالي غيرت اسرائيل اتفاقيه
السلام احد ملاحقها ووافقت ان مصر يكون
عندها قوات اكبر على الحدود المباشره مع
غزه بهدف تامين الحدود لكن ظلت الشكوى من
اسرائيل انه مازال في انا بشك ان في انفاق
بيطلع منها المقاومه قصه طويله عشان ما
اطولش عليك انما انت بتقول لي لو استمرت
فده بالنسبه ل فيلادلفيا يعني
اللي هي بتفكر دلوقتي اسرائيل عشان نكمل
في جمله مفيده بتفكر انها ترجع تاني تسيطر
عليه تسيطر عليه ليه لانها بتعتقد ان بما
ان في كم كبير جدا من السلاح اللي موجود
في غزه يبقى لا يمكن ان يكون الا ان الا
لا يمكن ان تكون الامور الا على النحو
الثاني
هناك مستمر بياتي لهذه المقاومه عبر سنين
و حتى الان من عبر سيناء اليها من اي مصدر
بقى من مص صر من ايران من تجار سلاح الى
اخره مصر بتنفي هم بيقولوا مافيش حل تاني
اكيد السلاح جاي من عندكم فاحنا حلينا بقى
ان انتم ان احنا نيجي نحتل
تاني ممر فيلادلفيا هو الاجابه انه او
يعني ده كلام انا اعتقد انه كلام في
الهواء هو عشان يجي ممر فيلادلفيا قدامه
عقبت اساسيتين وكل عقبه ليها
نقاط العقبه الاولانيه معناها ان هو مضطر
يكون موجود على الارض بقوات
وده هيصدمك كبيره جدا مع المقاومه اللي هو
مش عارف يحمي نفسه منها وهو مش موجود ثابت
حتى الان بعد 81 او 82 يوم اثنين انه اكتر
من كده هو لازم يهجر بيوت و مشي ناس عشان
يعمل منطقه عسكريه ودول في الغالب هيجوا
على مصر مصر هترفض هذا الكلام وهيبقى
صدام ف لازم تكون القوه الدوليه موافقه
الولايات المتحده وغيره وده امر صعب جدا
انت بتسالني رد فعل مصر رد فعل مصر اظن
انه يعني هو اللي حصل انا ارفض ده انا لا
اوافق على ده انا بقى مضطره لو وصلت
المساله الى فكره
انه مش عارف يعني تبقى فكره ايه يعني
هنتكلم على سيناريو صدام لا اعتقد لا مصر
عاوزاه ولا اسرائيل عاوزاه ولا اعتقد ان
الامور هتكون تصل الى هذا الحد لان
السناريو مخيف جدا الى درجه لا مصر تفكر
فيه ولا اسرائيل تفكر فيه واذكركم ان
اسرائيل قالت كلام كتير ثم تراجعت عنه هي
مش قادره على المقاومه هتفكر اللي هي فصيل
او عده فصائل في قطاع صغير هل تفكر في ان
هي ا تفتح جبهه مع مصر
مثلا وبعدين ممكن حل ثاني يعني لو احنا
بنتكلم لو الحرب صعبه ممكن جدا اذا كنتوا
انتوا بتقولوا ان الانفاق بتيجي من منها
اسلحه ومصر بتقول ما فيش ومصر حريصه ان ما
تكونش بلدها يعني
مفتوحه بشكل مباح لكل اللي من يريد ان
يعبر لان الاسلحه مش بس لان الانفاق دي مش
هتهدي اسلحه بس دي ممكن تمرر كل شيء يعني
ممكن بقى انه المساله بمباركه مصريه اذا
وصلت المسائل لاسوا حل انه الانفاق تفتح
للمقاومه عبر مصر الى ان ترتدع اسرائيل
انا طبعا لا اعبر عن حكومه مصريه انا بقول
يعني اذا وصلت المساله الى وضع سيء جدا
المواجهه لن تكون مستحيله ولكن مش لازم
تاخد شكل مواجهه تقليديه
يعني انا هستاذن كمان قدامنا الثلاث دقائق
او خمس
دقائق
ا ننهي يعني استاذ سييد هل تتوقع جبت
قرائتك لمستقبل غزه كيف ترى حضرتك المشهد
في ظل التطورات لا احد يا ف يا فاطيمه
ا يعني يستطيع القطع بمستقبل
غزه يعني يقينا انه الكلام عن القضاء على
حماس كلام في الهواء لكن يقينا ايضا انه
من الصعب جدا ان تعود الاوضاع كما كانت
عليه قبل يوم 7 اكتوبر يعني الخطه اللي
مصر بتقول عليها ربما تكون اقرب شيء
لل للي ممكن تمريره
يعني بس الحل انه تيجي حكومه انه يطلع بعض
القيادات
ودي ليها سابقه اصلا القيادات اللي موجوده
في قطر واللي كانوا موجودين قبل كده في
سوريا ما هم كانوا موجودين في في الاراضي
المحتله يعني وخرجوا فممكن بعض القيادات
ياخدوا ضمانات ويعيشوا في دوله يختاروها
الكلام عن الجزائر ماشي او غيرها وتطلع في
قيادات الصف الثاني تدير على يعني الميدان
وتحتفظ حماس ببنيتها وتبقى في حكومه
تكنوقراط على امل ان ده يتغير بعد فتره في
غزه يعني
اا ربما
ا هي مستقبل السودان مثل وجه ام مظفر
الرافضيه انا سامحني مش فاهم قصدك ايه
يعني يا عبد الرحمن مستقبل السودان يبقى
نعمل حلقه عن السودان بما انه كثير من
الاسئله في اللحظه الاخير على السؤال على
السودان
اا استاذنكم انا عارف ان انتوا يعني في حد
بيسال هو فين هاني جنينه هاني جنينه
صديقنا العزيز المحترم اقتصادي جميل وانا
قلت قبل كده ان هو الراجل ارتبط بعمل
في بنك استثماري يعني او شركه استشارات
وبيقدم استشاراته في ظروف وقته وطبيعه
عمله لا تسمح له ان يكون متواجدا في
الاعلام بشكل مستمر يعني فربنا يوفقه
ويسعده واحنا ان شاء الله عندنا تطوير في
قناه نعرف اقتصاد كنت اتمنى ان انا اعمله
يعني من فتره ولكن جاءت حرب غزه ولا صوت
يعلو فوق صوت لكن ان شاء الله خلال اسبوع
اسبوعين هيكون عندنا تغيير وتحديث لقناه
نعرف ويكون فيها يعني تدفق
و ان شاء الله شكل جديد يا رب هل ايران
تريد احتلال بقيه دول الخليج العربي بعد
العراق والله اشك في هذا يعني احترم فيك
هدوءك والمنطقيه بالطرح بتجرد وواقعيه
ومنكم نستفيد ربنا يخليك ايمن استاذ هل
تتوقع لقاء مباشر انا اجبت يا صديقي
اللقاء المباشر بين حبيبتي والبرهان اسمي
حسام الف شكر هل التهجير في غزه مازال
مطروح ا ربنا يخليك يا حسام ايوه التهجير
مطروح مطروح مطروح مطروح الان مطروح
ا مطروح مع بدايه حركه الصهيونيه من 100
سنه ارجع لحلقه عملتها مع الاستاذ الكبير
الدكتور علي الدين هلال عمل تاريخ جميل
عرض هائل لفكره التهجير مطروح في من مش من
100 سنه بس من 100 سنه ومن 50 سنه واثناء
النكبه الاولى طول الوقت هم بيحلموا بفكره
التهجير وبالمناسبه في هذا الاسبوع اساتذه
واكاديمي اسرائيليين مازالوا بيطرح وها
كفكره عبقريه كل الاطراف هتستفيد منها
الحلقه ان شاء الله اللي هنتكلم فيها اللي
هي كانت المفروض تذاع النهارده بس اعتقد
اذاعها بكره يكون احسن يعني عشان ما صدعكم
مرتين في يوم فيها اشاره الى هذا الموضوع
معلش انا عارف ان الاسئله كثيره جدا جدا
بس انا
استاذنكم يعني لاسباب ان يعني زي ما كنت
قلت لكم انا حابب اكمل بس يعني النفس
راغبه والجسد ضعيف يعني فان شاء الله اذا
كان الميعاد الساعه 7:00 ده مناسب اعدكم
باذن الله الاسبوع المقبل الساعه 7:00
نلتقي باذن الله انا شاكر جدا جدا لكم
وبعتذر جدا للاصدقاء انا ما تمكنت من
اجابه
اسئلتهم لكن باذن الله نلقاهم على خير
الاسبوع اللي جاي ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا
والى
اللقاء